[Music]
hello and welcome to trigonometry I'm
Frances Foster I'm Constance in kissin
and this is a show for you if you're
bored of people arguing on the internet
over subjects they know nothing about
trigonometry we don't pretend to be the
experts we ask the experts
[Music]
our amazing expert guests this week is
the director and founder of the
Institute of ideas
Claire Fox welcome to chicken entree
good to be here well thank you very much
for coming on the first question we
always like to ask my guest is how did
you get to where you are what's been
your story in your journey and actually
for many years I was a teacher and I
worked in further education and I was
passionate about aspects of education
that I thought were neglected and and
became interested in creating discussion
in debate I was also involved in
politics I took a year out from teaching
to relaunch what was living Marxism and
relaunch it as LM magazine and we
weren't pretending it had no
relationship to living masters which is
why I had LM but it also was a different
magazine in as much as the living
Marxism was set up by the revolution
Communist Party revolutionary communist
party closed down and there was this
magazine I thought was great I had a
readership and so I took the year out to
relaunch it with a colleague
Hellena Goldberg we did that you current
affairs magazine recognizing that we
were going to go across left and right
free speech magazine brilliant we got
sued for libel in the first issue so my
big break into and we got sued for libel
and we decided that as we were a free
speech magazine we weren't going to
shred the copies or tear it up or
apologize because we hadn't done
anything wrong and so we then spent the
next three years fighting a libel case
and bringing the magazine out and during
that time it got following a
subscription base in it
became very well known and one of the
things that we did was we launched the
summer of events called the Institute of
ideas and that was after we lost a libel
case but we kind of did this summer of
events anyway it was a sellout and then
we thought oh and then people came over
said you should do these debates you
know it's really important to have
discussions and why you know discuss
things on panels with people who aren't
just the obvious suspects and attract
particularly young people to come along
and debate
create a new public square so that was
it we carried on by accidents and that
that's kind of how I got where I am now
I was brilliant that that's what we
tried to do on here as well is to have
conversations with interesting people
just as we were talking before we
started you mentioned there were certain
areas of Education that you felt we're
not being properly catered to what
particularly well what I meant by that
was I was and this is kind of trigger
warning that old fogey comments coming
out and I felt that the young people I
was teaching were increasingly not aware
not widely read I taught in a further
education College I wasn't expecting
them to have kind of had access to the
Canon but I did think that there was a
closing down and a narrowing down of
what they knew even in terms of cultural
references an example that I use quite
often be this because it really struck
me at the time was you know I taught
English and I had to be saying right so
there's a there's a there's an Apple in
this poem what might that symbolize and
they would he'd like look at me I go an
apple you know like an apple and then I
realized that they didn't have any clue
about apples and Garden of Eden and you
know any of these kind of like potential
so I almost like and then you sort of
say this reminds me you know this is
like the 18th century what is that you
know 19th century 20s or anything
lovely was so I was frustrated by that
and also just politically I felt that
they were being ill served in terms of
getting a very insipid version of kind
of left-wing politics which I was
involved in left-wing politics but I
kind of knee-jerk one-dimensional
kind of version they've kind of lacking
politics that was respected that and so
I you know I just thought we just need
to have more debate and discussion that
these young people deserve to have a
kind of political culture that's rich
and open at the very time when it wasn't
rich and anchored and and and it was at
the start actually of you know it's kind
of Blair was coming you know so it was
kind of spin-doctors everything you know
technocratic technocratic politics no
ideals just at the time when
universities were beginning to kind of
deploy some of the postmodern tropes and
the kind of closing down of debate so I
was arrogant and I wanted to have a
decent magazine that maybe could read
that would be a bit different and
open-minded and bring into it people who
you wouldn't normally see in so the
first issue you had you know Roger
Scruton alongside some well-known left
wing commentators you know what I mean
like interesting people saying
interesting things that was what we did
well that sounds great and I your
Wikipedia page which I'm sure is the
best source of everything the most
accurate information about says that you
libertarian is that accurate because I
think not that late I think that what
has happened subsequent over the last
twenty years I don't mean to me but to
everyone is that nobody knows how to
label anyone anymore you know I came
from a Marxist background and I believe
in freedom this apparently is not
allowed in politics degrees everybody
good you can't be a Mercy's dinner you
know and I also aware of the fact that
you know Marxism is very important
philosophical outlook for me I have a
disavow it but I'm no longer involved in
an active Marxist organisation or
anything I consider myself to be on the
left but increasingly god knows what
that means and so I think that what's
happened over the years is that people
the one consistent thing that we can
work out about me is that I've
consistently argued for free speech I've
consistently argued for free thinking
they think that libertarian is the
appropriate
then they go with boat you don't appear
to be into the free markets and you know
so that's people get confused anyway I
can't be bothered to argue so what
exactly say I don't see libertarian as
an insult it's just that I wouldn't have
chosen that tag myself particularly
because to me being libertarian and
being absorbed associating yourself with
Marx's and they seem kind of polar
opposites in certain is well like that
they have become that I think I mean in
America libertarianism or kind of free
thinking and the left is not such an
alien concept but in the UK it has
become that and that's all I'm saying is
I don't even know what libertarian I
mean if if it's men you believe in
freedom no ifs no buts then I'm not
arguing in terms of where these strictly
where these political labels come from
probably I don't quite fit into either
that so I kind of let it ride and as I
said don't bother arguing with Wikipedia
which is not there's no point arguing
with that
so let's come back to the kids to
education because one of the things I've
listened to a few things that you were
talking about snowflakes and it's the
snowflake culture and we've everybody
being hypersensitive everybody feeling
like a victim you wrote I find that
offensive
tell us a little bit about what's going
on in our universities and then schools
and why are people now are they first of
all becoming more sensitive and if so
why yes I one thing that Wikipedia does
say is if you look at generation
snowflake it says Claire Fox is
responsible for introducing this term
into the UK and that was an entirely
fictitious but I sort of know what they
mean because in I find that offensive
which is just a short book on free
speech I talked about a phrase that was
emerging in American universities of
generation snowflake and I decided that
I would write the book about and two
generations snowflake and so that's kind
of how I suppose it became associated
with the term but I'm aware of the fact
that it's an incredibly insulting
caricatured term and in fact I don't use
it in that kind of you know new
generations snowflake you're hopeless
what I was interested in excuse me well
why I was interested in was why young
people
and I had observed this myself because I
had a lot of talks in schools and
universities and so on seem to be
increasingly thin-skinned and easily
offended and rather than arguing back
which is entirely appropriate now I go
and speak you this button to argue about
people say you can't say that then
getting upset I find that offensive you
can't say that and it was kind of like
I'm so I can't I'm so developing a
reputation we're going in and talking to
17 year olds I'm kind of ending up in
tears I mean it was a kind of peculiar
shift in a way they weren't kind of
[ __ ] or argumentative or or even
kind of silently suddenly flowering at
me they were getting upset and they it
was almost as though they couldn't
believe that anyone would say certain
things and so I I and and I was aware of
the shifts in the university culture
which is in fact sadly intensifying
which is at university which after all
almost 50% of the Kobalt go to
university so we're not talking about a
small group of this generation that
there was an increasing tendency to
argue for the protection of students
from Dangerous Ideas and the whole
emergence of safe space culture in
particular preoccupied me it wasn't so
much no platforming no platforming was
around when I was at university a
million years ago and although it's now
broadened who is no platformed and
there's well-known examples of you named
one feminists grief banning another
feminist you know Germaine Greer and all
all of these kind of examples the real
issue that fascinated me was safe spaces
and trigger warnings the idea that you
would go leave home and go on this
exciting intellectual journey to
university and immediately demand
demanded the authorities that they make
you feel safe seemed extraordinary to me
I mean this is a period at which the one
thing you don't want historically if
you're young is to be looked after and
feel safe that's the aspiration of you
know old-age pension you wanna do these
days the old-age pensioners are all
going off you know tripped around the
world and
experimenting but you want them to bust
out of this right there there is a
generation that demands that they feel
safe and comfortable and don't have
their ideas disturbed I was anxious that
this was a problem and but no that's
really really interesting what you say
that where do you think that comes from
this idea that I don't want to have my
views challenged I want to feel safe is
it because we morally mollyconor them
too much as kids because you know
because of the right-wing tabloid press
you know Peter files and all the rest of
it is it the fact that you know that
children and now they're getting ferried
to and from school is it the fact that
now we indulge them you know they're you
know you can fulfill your dreams at
everybody's special even though we're
not there's a billion of us no one's
gonna miss us if we die yeah all of that
so had in a way that's why I wrote the
book or what the books about because we
because actually I didn't want to try
and write a book about free speech in as
much as it's been some fantastically
brilliant books written about free
speech and I thought I had nothing to
contribute I wanted to try and
understand what I'd created generation
snowflake and so I said by time they get
to go to university or leave home
they're already preloaded with anxieties
and one of the things that I talked
about is a kind of safety first culture
in which we've socialized the kids
basically as parents as teachers
particularly social policy in education
policies you say you know we scare
monger everything right I mean you know
eating too much sugar is like the
greatest catastrophe that's gonna kill
all the children there's an obesity time
bomb it's called crack okay and their
childhood in the House of Commons that's
like having a bar a chocolate right I'm
gonna fizzy drink there isn't anything
that we say to young people is kind of
like it's alright you'll cope you know
we basically scare monger all the time
catastrophize is the word that I use a
terrible word but anyway and so in a way
we've kind of introduced young people
from very early agents telling them that
the will is the scariest place in the
world and the role of adults
historically was you know you get kid
right when you're a kid I need you know
when I was your type young child I scare
in the dark and I always thought that
the jacket beyond the door
Muenster and you know the dressing and
whatever right and obviously the role of
the idol is to cover an ensign there it
sort of acts nice no no you stop having
it's a vivid imagination to reassure you
now if you say I think there's a monster
I'd behind the door they'll be child
favoring child protection rights oh god
that probably is oh my god you know so
the adults don't reassure the young they
make it worse
and you're pedophiles right I don't know
that that's the right-wing tabloid press
can be entire just blame for that I mean
we have become obsessed with child abuse
children being at risk and so all sorts
of well-known things of emerge from this
like children not playing outside
anymore and over mollycoddled
over terrified of every kind of stranger
danger that you can possibly have and
then told even that if they stay at home
and kind of stick in their bedroom
they're gonna be groomed by sex gangs
online and you know everything is a sort
of threat so I think that that has
created an over anxiety once you people
I mean that's the kind of culture in
which they are growing up at the same
time unprepared to deal with the
rough-and-tumble of everyday life
because they also then don't have an
opportunity to experiment take risks
make mistakes so they are kind of
infantilized much later and mollycoddled
in the way that you say and then there's
a hole in the story about the
self-esteem movement in the way that you
said people are special and so you get a
combination of kind of thin-skinned
a was scared youth and he were also
think they're very special the most
important person in the world and
there's nothing more toxic than that mix
I think so obviously not every single
young person is like that okay that is
the climate in which they are
socializing it is a generational trend
though I mean you know I insist on that
because obviously I taught this bill
it's a lots of young people and it's you
know you can kind of get this like well
I'm not like that but that's you know
you have to be able to discuss
generational trends the model that we
have of young people is that they need
to be protected they're vulnerable
they're at risk of mental illness
there's anxiety rampaging through this
generation we're told that they've never
same with any previous young generation
that makes me laugh I mean that's the
idea well you know what because you were
talking that I was actually thinking it
makes sense that they would be the most
anxious generation in history because if
you've been coddled in the way that
you've described all your life you you
feel utterly unprepared for the real
world and you know at some level that
the real world is full of challenges and
adventures and dangers and you know that
you are not prepared anxiety is exactly
the right response to that situation so
that's what happens is it go it becomes
a fait accompli you know it becomes a
kind of so in that sense it's not made
up it's a contrived thing there might be
an opportunistic Student Union officers
who kind of use these tropes to close
down debate in a kind of very
opportunist getting the papers you know
we're not having this prism but most
people actually are scared of words and
scared of these things but I think the
reason I'm saying this is that you know
in response to some of the educational
pressures that young people face a
constant diet of exams there are
problems in schools I appreciate that
and but but but the adult community the
the teaching unions lots of teachers
their parent sort of saying you are
making our children mentally ill and
because they've got the stress of exams
coming up and you think no it's called
it's damn stress you'll make at least
stress before an exam I mean it's not
like everything is talked up and it then
people like accumulate both the language
and the lack of resilience that means
that it does become a real problem
you didn't go at university and somebody
says now you actually have to read some
books and at the end of it you know when
you can't take the books into the exam
with you the end and they can't cope
right they just can't cope in a way and
you know there's it's actually it comes
just for leaving home because you don't
know anyone you have to you know but
this is called growing up it's exciting
you can look at it as an exciting
adventure or a scary moment and more and
more see in the scary moment phrase and
but the point about this sort of the way
that the these things opposes if you
think about some of the generational
debates that we have at the moment
people say you know you're being
betrayed by baby boomers they're facing
unprecedented pressures I mean on
precedent
Britain in 2018 unprecedented pressure
no young people a beverage soft with the
way these young people suffer right and
when I say how said well you know you
can't buy a house before you 24 think
wow that is not a great hardship right
it might not be great I mean I didn't
buy my first ask till I was four eight
and I thought it was a great privilege
to be able to write I mean first of all
is a little classic question there as an
aside but also unprecedented pressures
you know like cyberbullying you know
never mind
kids going up chimneys or down mines or
having to leave school at 14 or being
recruited into the army all of this
right no cyberbullying you know and how
can they possibly cope because they
judge themselves on how many likes they
go and the pressures of Instagram and
this is driving them I don't mean these
are new pressures and interests but this
is not an on you know the idea that
they're suffering more than any other
generation it seems unlikely to me is
because I still work in a school a
couple of days a week and I mean we
infantilized children and of course it
sounds like an oxymoron but we really do
I mean I remember one teacher came up to
me was right oh look what my like seven
year-olds created and he showed me a
picture of a macaroni picture and I was
just like look seven-year-old to make my
trainers do you see what I mean we just
think that they can't do these things
and children are far more capable and
resilient than you that give them credit
for
so we're dragging that away from them
yes we're robbing them
so my bog in a way was saying without
letting the kids I thought my book was
saying it's awful do you see what I mean
so what I was trying to say yes we have
created you know we've created their own
Frankenstein monster then when they take
it to the logical degree at university
and start banning us from coming in
we're all like oh my god that's
outrageous and what's wrong with them
and then we Lampoon them has been these
thin-skinned but actually it's the
culture that they've come through
exactly in the way that you said and I
mean I mean you see it so often like
that I taught a girl a few a few weeks
ago and she broke her foot and of course
you know this would be upsetting for her
she's only ten years old she broke her
foot
her parents wheeled her in in a
wheelchair I mean what what was wrong
with just giving her a couple of
crutches and look I'm certain you
brought your foot that's a bit upsetting
be not what this is life you're just
gonna have to get on with it
instead of wheeling her around in a
wheelchair
it just seems excessive like you know
the kids come all mr.foster look I've
got a little cut on my finger
great get on with it we seem to have
forgotten or hardcore yeah we seem to
have forgotten that and actually a lot
of the times in life you just need to
suck it up and get on with it but not
your child goes to Francis school you
know by the way I define him watch here
I would like to say Francis was not
defending child labour but you do make a
good point about about you know what we
expect because I think that one of the
examples I give is you know where two
young people by 18
how have they developed this notion that
words that the same as violence you know
what why would work why would they think
that
right and then you look at the growth of
the anti-bullying movement in schools
and you can see where it comes from so
traditionally bullying horrible things
happens okay right every kid is bullied
but you know you some kid comes in and
says I'm being bullied you still think
ah you know that's terrible you sort of
are visions of them being totally
intimidated by you know people who were
you know kicking their head in and
stealing their money and just cruelty
and all the rest of it and then he sort
of said was happening you all right
and then one what actually my niece
Greta she hates me telling this story
actually it's in the book but my niece
said yeah because you know that all the
girls that going out and that gets a
picture on Friday night and that and I'm
not coming and then they haven't invited
me and I said oh because I thought oh my
god the poor kids so distraught yeah and
I said that's not bullying happy that's
like going out with you you know and
she's like no it's bullying anyway she
goes into it anyway I suddenly see the
school policy is that bullying includes
exclusion from friendship group so she
was right and I was wrong and these are
the bullying rules on their wall right
so if he's so I started to look at this
was
some years ago but I started to look at
anti-bullying policies and they have
just expanded exponentially what
constitutes bullying and so it's like
you know aggressive gestures nobody
nobody is you know some bullying looks
all this sort of thing so and so you
have that kind of growth of what
bullying is it counts as bullying you
tell kids that if anything's happened to
you you are being bullied you then look
at the anti-bullying literature and the
experts in bullying and the people who
have given you know there's so large
organizations and are advising
governments and schools and all the rest
and they say if you're bullied at school
it will have lifelong damaging impacts
and will lead to years of trauma and
mental health problems and might mean
that you are unemployable unemployed you
know that your life's gonna be ruined
right so we tell kids that being
excluded from friendship groups is
bullying and we then say that bullying
making no distinction between that and
getting your head kicked in and will
destroy your life so no wonder if you're
11 and you're being bullied that not
only is it not very nice when it happens
to you but you then think it's gonna
ruin your life and you therefore imagine
that when people say horrible things to
you that this is going to destroy you
and it that exacerbates the problem
right I mean as it happens even if the
worst kind of bullying sound to you I
don't think it's going to destroy your
life and I think it's the role of adults
to how we will get over that and to
learn to cope with it but that's not
what they're told but they're also tell
the most trivial silly acts of cruelty
by one child to another is going to have
this long lasting impact and I think
then that makes people think oh you know
I'm being bullied online somebody said
they don't like my dress and somebody to
call me fat and somebody said that I'm
and that somebody's prettier that and by
time you get through that whole thing
and the thing is gonna destroy your life
that actually makes you anxious yeah and
you know actually you can't cope so you
then associate horrible words and this
is where the free speech issue comes
with having a damaging traumatic impact
on people so of course this becomes
theorized around trigger warnings and
safe spaces and so on we have to
those people from speaking because their
words are harmful just like the physical
act I've been punched in the stomach or
kicked in the head the words are harmful
and the term harm is now become a kind
of existential I don't like it and Jas
Mills harm principle now incorporates
harm in this kind of very broad
therapeutic meaning of the sense of the
word the thing I'm worried about kids is
a nature of victimhood and that
everybody nowadays seems to be a victim
everybody you know has something or you
know and you know that everybody is
being oppressed and I just find it
worrying because if you have their
attitude like you said you are going to
collapse when the moment you face
adversity and what we're not teaching
kids in school and I'm as guilty of it
as anyone as being a teacher is we're
not teaching them resilience I teach
kids so often and I give them all the
strategies I'd teach year six so that's
10 and 11 year olds and I give them all
the strategies and then they understand
it and when I give them questions 1 to
10 where they follow along to the
pattern they can do it the moment you've
is slightly to the right or to the left
and ask them for a bit of independent
thought they come up against the barrier
they give up pencil goes down head goes
down and if you do that at 10 and that's
not we don't nip that in the bud that is
gonna Korean adult who simply is not
gonna fight well I think that's the
thing is that vulnerability in the sense
that you are vulnerable which is the
consequence of a climate that scaling is
about everything you are the vulnerable
one constantly it threat for everything
and the food that you drink to the
people that you mate it and some and so
forth creates the victim doesn't it I
mean that's what you see yourself in
that particular way the converse of that
of course is that any young person he
kind of is a bit bolshy
and a bit um you know I'm not you know
tries to say I'm not that bothered or
doesn't appear to adopt that kind of is
its treated as though they're either in
denial or as though they're kind of like
insensitive and in fact one of the
things that the again the kind of thing
rising on the free-speech issue is to
say that somebody like me who's
critiquing generation snowflake is that
I am insensitive you know I am the kind
of person who doesn't understand the
suffering of the vulnerable young and
some of the the responses to the boat
were really interesting because I was
really nervous I thought God middle-aged
woman critique generations know if I'm
gonna get hammered well every young
person gonna think I'm an idiot right
and you know it's a kind of cultural
middle-aged woman attacking the young
and I was nervous actually I've had a
much more positive response from young
people I believe absolutely hate the
book and his you know written horrible
reviews about it have largely been
people who work in educational
psychology social workers you know that
kind of will I my peers in the kind of
world of policy you think that I am and
big horrible about and to young people
and then they'll say oh Claire Fox is
just the sort of person who thinks that
everybody needs to be bullied in order
to harden up Claire Fox is a sort of
person they know somebody's cutting
themselves you know and self harm says
get on with it I don't clean them Alyssa
Lee so your character chilled as a as a
you know kind of hard-nosed
mean-spirited ungenerous person and I
can live with all that what I'm saying
is for people growing up then the model
thought if you're going to get some sort
of like hearing is that you are the
sensitive easily offended and you know
vulnerable person if you somebody who
actually can brush it off and get on
with it
you're seen to be somehow some kind of
psychotic lunatic who's not in touch
with their feelings right and there's
something wrong with you you're the
person that's problematic so of course
you know people learn that in order to
kind of gain the respect of the adult
worlds and of society they actually have
to play the victim card and I think that
that's kind of a it's not the political
form it takes but I think it gives a
sort of sense of the world in which some
of these big political disputes on free
speech occur and you can then see that
it's playing the victim card in terms of
identity politics
accruing more and more examples of one's
own vulnerability versus you know
the absolute villain of the piece in
terms of identity politics and
intersectionality which is the the white
male and it's always kind of like the
white male stiff upper lip so again it's
this sort of hard-nosed you know anima
where is the emotionally sensitive
vulnerable person who feels the pain
they are the ones that everyone says
what a wonderful person this person over
there is written off as some kind of
monster for not being in touch with
their emotional angst now how much of
this do you think is an exaggerated
sense of compassion this idea
essentially that being compassionate is
so much more important than being
practically helpful to a young person
that I mean that's fundamentally we're
talking about being compassionate is not
always the best strategy for helping you
I personally I think compassion I'm a
bit of a fan of compact I think I'm much
not quite the term I think compassion
it's all right but you get that but this
is a kind of be cruel to be kind
or in as much as you know like am as a
teacher you know you go and see if you
go into a class and say you know what do
you want me to teach you want me to
teach you know kind of poetry is rap
music only intention the blue X of
rappers poetry or do you want me to hand
in the fourth part one right it's very
raps much more relevant and then he's
saying good we're not doing that with
Jane only the fourth part right because
yeah I don't need to teach you that but
you do need to do this you have to work
right on there well I don't want to do
what's the point in doing Jane Austen's
good you know what's the point no I'm
not doing that what's the point of
course you know you have been very
unpopular for a period of time know
young people do not want to learn what
they are entitled to know it's pretty
obvious you know main thing when I'm a
great time or they don't and then when I
met their brain hair or there's not
easily accessible and adults have lost
the courage to look young people in the
eye and say I don't care that you don't
want to know this you are going to well
that's what I meant
yeah I know but I but I think all I'm
saying is I think it's compassionate to
give them what they need to know right
but I mean I've never framing my oh yeah
but i but i but i think i think what i'm
saying is that you want to be cruel to
be kind to be compassionate absolutely I
don't think that kind of fawning over
the young and there once is doing them
any favors at all I think it's a major
betrayal and I also think it shows a
certain indifference to them because
you're basically more interested in
being popular with them than in actually
giving them what they're entitled to and
for me generation is a generational
transaction you know you you know I have
a tiny weeny little bit of understanding
about the best that's known and sought
not very much but it's tiny little bit
right and and a little bit I've got I
want to pass on you know I I am for me
it's like you you you you should know
this stuff right this is like the
greatest ideas in the world and I want
you to have it I'm passing it on to you
and we don't do that now right we kind
of go this is the great stuff that
that's known in the world but we were
worried that it was created by white
philosophers around you as a slave trade
so it's not that great after I might
have to renew it all and review it but
you interesting fifteen-year-old digital
native you really do know interesting
stuff right I can learn from you and
that's the you know when he said what's
happening education it was that
turnaround right it was that shift that
beginning to be the shift in educational
terms which was teachers were told that
they had to be you know guides on the
side you know and we can learn from the
stages that let facilitators analyst and
and I'd say no you know I I and and of
course he even got the confidence to do
it I mean I was in a great teacher but I
was a good teacher you know and and but
I would get you know these kind of tough
because I talk white kids really and but
you know you'd get these kind of like
kids be complete specially you know some
of the lads be like are my you've seen
and then you kind of get a rather
sensitive essay on the latest Jane
Austen novel written and of course they
wouldn't admit that in class and it took
me a nearly a year to get them to me
even read the bloody thing and then I
read it and I something I get this essay
so you know it's really important that
dilemmas that Emma would go through oh
yeah is that little secret between them
in me that they have discovered
bit of literature and a little
sensitivity now I wasn't a nice man I
didn't really hiring classes yet so mop
right I knew they knew a little thing
had occurred in our lessons
they'd learned something they've read a
novel and also I'd given them a gateway
to potentially some literature that was
the least I could do that just doesn't
happen and in fact I would consider to
be some sort of like old-fashioned
dinosaur type for giving a lecture you
know that fecal because in an Fe College
where it kind of it's kind of wet
clothes kids not to say kind of greats
like academics you know I I insisted on
doing lectures you know you have to
listen write notes generally I'd make a
bit of a point about the fact they had
to read the books in the reading
literature all this other things
constantly I was considered to be sort
of a lunatic
I know do great work ask them what they
think but I don't think anything cuz I
would talk them anything yet what I can
get them to sit in groups and talk about
a novel they haven't read and they
haven't thought I mean this is just
self-indulgent nonsense it's a
fascinating point because I'm thinking
back as you're talking about teaching to
my school days and I'm my favorite
teacher I didn't even like him but he
was my favorite teacher because he made
sure that I learned what I needed and I
had a healthy respect for him but I
wouldn't say that I felt some great
affinity yet to him and if I think back
through the great teachers it was much
more about respect and them teaching me
something as opposed to liking them this
is my great self justification for
whatever you like me no but I mean I
think that's the I think that's the
balance I'm Johnny Sian I think this is
taken away from me or teaching but maybe
just just a sort of and I think that
there's a collapse of adult authority in
the world and I think what I was trying
to anti-bullying and a belief in the
kind of values of the world do you know
saying so for me that's the greatest
betrayal and so generation snowflake in
a way is kind of but scamming and I also
this kind of inability as I say to look
the young and the eye and kind of say to
them these things matter you know this
is right and this is wrong this is a
dispute about what would be right and
wrong but have the courage to do it well
I don't
what do you think I mean he you know who
cares what they think I'd see I
completely agree with you because I used
to teach in the London borough of new
which is one of the poorest boroughs in
London and you I'd get these kids coming
up and they hadn't been taught the
basics no one ever explains him and
every time in the first lesson I'd say
to them here's the thing I'm your
teacher I'm not your mate I don't care
what you think your behavior is a choice
you choose to behave you've come in to
learn if you choose to misbehave you not
only damage your own education you
damage the education of everyone around
you and here's the thing most kids would
die to be in your position so if you're
going to behave like that I've got no
interest out you go
and most of them actually even like the
suppose I mean there's always one or two
but the vast majority went okay and if
they could see themselves learning and
progressing they liked it kids crave
boundaries and all that these people do
these adults do who like all what do you
think it's just not just accept that
you're a weak person because that's all
you are what kids want of any age is to
go this is it this is what you need to
do here it is and I'm sorry but you got
to work well there's a big argument
going on in schools at the moment which
you probably may be familiar with and
actually somebody be good for you to
interview maybe on this is Tom Bennett
who's the behaviors are for the
government but I think that title is mad
but anyway he's great guy and he's
interesting and he and I argue over lots
and lots of things but what he's really
good at this behavior in schools but one
of the things that happens is that if
you are somebody who says that this
should be quite a strict behavior code
in schools and this could these can be
able codified in some of the strictest
schools kind of slightly drive me mad by
kind of almost thinking it's a technical
activity you know everything these so
rules basement yeah they've kind of lost
sight of what it is they're trying to do
having said that the the opposite side
of the argument there basically says you
know putting somebody in detention is
the equivalent of putting them into in
or like sort of like like prison and
depriving I mean the hyperbole deployed
by people to discredit and D legitimize
a perfectly reasonable way of organizing
a school is incredible and I think
that's what you know something you're
recognizing I suppose with these films
which is you know these are then it
starts being a debate I mean if what you
do is simply demonizes beyond the pale
somebody's baked like into child abuse
because they believe in disciplining
gates that isn't our discussion right
that is not anyway kind of a thing and
you it means there's nowhere to go with
it
there's nowhere there's nowhere to have
a fruitful conversation and I find that
I wanted one of the things that happened
to me quite early on in when I started
writing about education because when I
was teaching I was also writing about
education and but as that's how I got
more interested in getting and
publishing the magazine issue I mean
because I kind of started to be
interested in a different kind of
journalism and getting the word out I
realized I could have a bit of an
influence and and you can't it's hard to
do that when you work full-time for an
institution these days because they
don't like you I mean all those days
anyway because you know you could get
disciplined and so on and so forth so
anyway and I one of the things I noticed
was I'd be arguing what I thought were
completely reasonable things about
educational standards and we have some
of these things right and I I've been
teaching for some years before I did my
PGCE you didn't have to have a
qualification to teaching further
education at one point and then it kind
of changed it so I thought about rush
often get my gray so I went to Greenwich
University and his point as it was then
get my PGCE water I mean talk about you
know intellectual nonsense I mean I kind
of was shocked at what was passing for
educational theory but anyway I'd argue
through these things I mean was studying
up in the class and denouncing me as
that kind of factor right right-wing
fascist because I'd say I believed in
discipline right you know when I kind of
argued for you know one girl stood up in
the class if she was trying to be
teacher with me
were all kind of you know I'm a late 20s
there's something like that she said I
can't believe you said that you know I
failed every example all through my life
and you're basically writing me off as a
failure and I was thinking of course no
disrespect but what are you doing on
this yeah yes
if you fail every exam it probably means
something yeah yeah the idea that I
should kind of summarize like and she
said this is the system that oppresses
the working class they say it doesn't
work plus people pass exams all the
bloody Lansing right and all this kind
of thing and then and then kind of and I
got a reputation during the year there I
was
lefty Marx's teacher and but was that
character joining me is like oh she's
just like a Daily Mail right and I
realized that this was just a way trying
to close you down and close down debate
and as it happens on the Left
historically internationally high
standards of Education and left-wing
thinking are actually bedfellows not the
opposite you know or there's no me and
the idea that the kind of history of
radicalism is based on some kind of
Philistine you know we shouldn't ask me
was doing sums in case they fail and
then it doomed them to being oppressed I
mean that's just not what it's about at
all
examines it happens by the way were
brought in and supported by trade unions
because they were meritocratic because
they took no interest in people's
background they simply measured whether
you'd achieved or not and I always find
that rather inspiring universal
aspiration Oh anyone can sit the exam
and anyone can do really well until then
that was very although you can argue
that tour too far left end of the
spectrum that when it comes to the
left-wing it eventually ends up in
shutting down ideas so if you know you
know a Cuba for example or Venezuela
I've got there's loads of exam and I
understand that but all I'm saying is
like yes but I say I don't that's kind
of practical examples of countries that
basket cases and I agree yeah but I'm
for free speech I was simply saying that
in terms of its philosophical traditions
yes associates the left with being
apologies for philistinism yeah or for
failure effective yeah yeah well let me
drag the two of you away from education
sorry
very bit on education I think it's great
well actually I think the things that
the other things we're very good to talk
to you about it they're kind of the
adult manifestation of some of the
things that you're talking about with
kids which is a culture of
hypersensitivity and partly what you
just talked about which is a culture of
saying if you don't agree with me you're
evil if you don't agree with me you are
that other thing that must not be
engaged to it and wherever we look at
the kind of identity politics which you
referred to whether it's modern feminism
or any other things that happen within
that identity politics bracket they all
seem to be subject to this complete
inability or unwillingness to actually
debate things which is what you've
created with the Institute of ideas and
them debating things that you do how why
do you think being able to discuss ideas
are so important well I mean first of
all because there's no I I do not
believe that I have stopped changing my
mind about things and so I think is and
you know the ability to hear other
opinions and could mean that I might
change my mind and or improve the way I
argue or just get a new perspective on
the world so I'm from an entirely
personal point of view I think it's a
peculiar idea to have in your head that
you know you at any age say this is what
I think and that's it and we never will
it ever change I mean obviously as you
get older you're more accustomed to
having developed and thought about this
but I mean nonetheless Wilmont to be
open all the time the world changes as
well so you need to be able to take
account of things that change
sorry that seems to me to be so
important because this idea that you
sort of psych right this one I think I'm
never gonna think anything else I mean
you might amuse hide under the bed I
mean what does that mean I mean you just
say you know how boring would mean that
you'd read a book and nothing would
occur I mean you know then you'd never
be able to watch a podcast and your
brain work because you'd say no no no no
this is what I think I'm nothing else
will you know so for me it's because we
all don't we and want to access new
ideas to stimulate ourselves to kind of
test that and also because by the way
there's a lot of problems in the world
that needs solving
I don't need this many people kind of
addressing them as possible and you need
to be open minded to consider that I
think as well the intellectual life by
the way is exciting and I think that you
know there's nothing more brilliant than
when you read a novel or you read an
I've just read underwear Hagen's essay
on Granville in the London Review of
Books it's it's like something like
30,000 it might even be longer think
thousand words mysteries like a little
book I mean just I learned is the most
perfect essay and it makes you think
it's shocking it's moving it reveals new
information it's a brilliant piece of
journalism is fantastically important
wherever understanding the world and
demos have just brought out a new report
on nostalgia which is based on the
notion that probably people voted brexit
and populism in France and Germany based
on nostalgia a thesis which I completely
disagree with but the report is
well-written it's got great quotes in it
I loved it I kind of learned a huge
amount from it so I didn't grow the
thesis boost one time and you know and
then I kind of bore everyone recharge
how good you've got read the demos bonus
oh you got me the Ella as I'm doing with
you because you know things I didn't
know it's not feasible so I believe
everyone's like that and everyone should
be like that and ideas are important
because society cannot move on cannot
resolve any problems cannot solve the
problems of humanity if we're not
constant
intellectually open to each others
developing ideas people who were bright
in the most taking ideas from 2,000
years ago and thinking about how they
apply today people who were not as
bright as us but I've got an absolutely
sharp wit who see something in a
different way
people whose experiences are different
which is why you know identity politics
is one of the great tyrannies of our
time but that's not to say that you
don't want to have any knowledge of
somebody's personal experience through
that that created by their energy
because that can give you a great
insight as well so of course the
frustration of this kind of stratified
static dead intellectual climate that we
live in I could speak on this I know you
don't don't speak to me I refuse to
listen well I think it's more than that
actually I think quite often now it's
not that someone will say you said this
thing and you're wrong no it's not even
that it's you're evil you're bad you
have no right you are white or you are
well they know what I mean so it's not
just what you it's not just what you're
allowed to discuss today it's who's
given permission to discuss it and
that's become very problematic and of
course because it becomes impossible to
have a discussion about confronting
racism or any issues in relation to
racism if you want from an ethnic
minority and because it becomes ever
more divisive by the way because then
you kind of get people saying oh well
you know it's already well Megan Markel
because she can pass for white so she's
not kind of right kind of black or then
you get the kind of disputes around
politics kanye west you know wrong kind
of politics so he's an Uncle Tom because
he looks like he's the point so even
within the identity groups that are
given permission you actually can only
follow one script anyway as it goes and
it becomes particularly unpleasant in
that way of sort of like accruing you
know I I'm a you know cuz I always make
the point you well when people say I
find that offensive I mean they're not
just telling you I mean they're saying I
find that offensive
shut up yeah it's not like just an
observation
and of course it's given an added moral
weight today when you say you know as a
woman I find that offensive I mean
that's it right well then that's not an
office
as a Muslim woman I find that offensive
you know as a disabled trans woman you
know and son it's alright it's like
you're accruing all the time because
it's like sort of ratcheting up how can
I stop you know what's my unique
position to say this and not
it's like creates a field around you
once you've said as a woman I find that
offensive
that means no one's allowed to comment
it creates a culture of fear because
then what you're saying is that my
opinion it's worth more than yours and
also as well you're potentially now
entering into the realms of racism and
intolerance and if you enter into the
realms of racial intolerance and that
label sticks to you that can affect
everything from how the way people see
you to your career prospects and it is a
feeling of terror and we all feel that
at certain points when we engage in
these topics of conversation I do it and
I start getting worried you know I call
it sweaty back syndrome where you just
think on my word have I said the wrong
thing can I be misinterpreted am I gonna
look racist sexist whatever it is and
can you imagine what it's like so so so
that is entirely accurate and I think
you only have to look at what's
happening on American campuses to see
how far we could go we're only starting
and we're usually kind of behind the
trends in terms of America just in terms
of the number of people who are being
sacked and you know people being a
kicked out of universities and so on and
so forth Amin expelled and as you say
it's not just that they've been called
race I mean you know once you've got
that label I mean you know and obviously
because I'm not interested in you know
because it's like the what its kind of
the worst thing isn't it you know
misogynist racist you know bigger right
you'll never work again but it's not
just that anyway I'm not a bloody bigot
so you don't want you know it's like
it's like a horrible thing you spend the
whole time having to get out of the
straitjacket of that term but the other
thing about the the terror is can you
imagine what it's like for people who
are no Fey with the rules I mean we know
the rules right what happens is is it
for millions and millions of men
the millions and millions of people in
this country right they haven't the know
the rules of intersectionality what
language you can use they can
inadvertently wander in and say
something perfectly reasonably in good
faith and can be absolutely castigated
humiliated you know and thrown to the
dogs maybe it's so unpleasant
and I think it's difficult if you know
the rules but it's just that people will
break the rules inadvertently you know I
remember I mean this is quite a
controversial one but you know the gay
marriage issues fascinating for me
because many years nobody demanded gay
marriage I mean it really wasn't a big
issue on in the kind of LGBT community
just wasn't nobody was kind of it wasn't
like a big radical demand people weren't
actually it was some people like me but
it wasn't a big thing largely because I
think in the kind of lesbian gay culture
that being the kind of like you know
we're not winded wouldn't know you
shouldn't boys were married you know
it's like you know the way we might
equality we don't want to be treated
differently but we're not married you
wasn't the big thing anyway within six
months or something you know David
Cameron announced it's gonna bring in
get a Tory he's gonna bring in gay
marriage and silly you had to agree with
gay marriage or you were a homophobic
bigot no I mean it was like there wasn't
even there wasn't a campaign there was
no argument there was no debate and I
think perfectly reasonably you know
friends and mine and family from you
know from Mike from where I'm from I
less in the clan over intellectual world
and so on we're a bit like I couldn't
they were a bit bemused I mean they
weren't particularly lost I mean I
didn't go on marches against it but they
saw was that lets me gain my God why
does it man want to marry a man or a
woman want to I was at all those back
was realized bigots you know it's not
kind of homophobic deplorable school
that how would you move just works out
that you're meant to change your mind
marriage has been between people of
opposite sex sexes for a very long time
you come along and declare from on high
but if you don't agree with that you're
a bigot
without ever trying to convince anyone
and that was it it's a very effective a
Katsura isn't it
and it make when it made me realize how
scary it was because I find it very
tricky to kind of have that argument and
even now I'm sort of like I'm not a
bigot I don't know what to think and but
it was the speed with which you had to
learn the language right and that people
would go on to and sort of say I'm not
sure about gay marriage of him saying
there's really a problem of you know
then he's going at re-education course
thing and I think that what happens then
is is that it silences many people it
effectively kicks them out the public
square because they know that they don't
know how to react or there's a kind of
underground reaction to it and I can't
and this can take quite an unpleasant
form some time which is to kind of
associate yourself with people who play
on the bigotry question a bit because
you kind of you just aware the fact that
you're walking on eggshells the whole
time you can't say what you think you
you're frightened that you might get
done over for saying the wrong thing
you're sweaty back point that happens to
so many people what what what that
either does is kind of kills a soul and
you right it keeps you out public
disgust right it means that you're not
allowed to ever speak again you have to
go away drop at politics drop everything
or you can only do it in the kind of
most clandestine underground sort of
sense and very often with young people
that can take the form of a kind of a
reaction I kind of quite reactionary
reaction sorry I know and that's why we
have you here keep talking I was very
upset recently about what happened at
Warwick University um I went to war at
university so I kind of just eleven
students I was a facebook private
Facebook oh yeah yeah twelve students
involved in at lads and they they had
conversations on their Facebook that
were met to open where they made some of
them make rape jokes and some of them
said some pretty racially insensitive
things say the least
but in my opinion first of all it was a
private conversation once twelve people
for me it was an insight into if you
make everything verboten the kind of
childish reaction is to kind of tell the
bad jokes that he's not meant to tell I
on the one hand one of those people
reported them they've now been suspended
from university their lives are
destroyed effectively and they've been
accused of being part of the rape
culture and that and it's gonna let them
back in some of them are gonna be
lawyers that's that that that's that
they're dispensable collateral damage in
the culture wars of today right vile
behavior in my view and so private
conversation no longer private so good
news and then there's sort of front
pages of the local newspapers and of the
student paper that women at work
universities are frightens across campus
because they think there's gonna be rape
so I mean these are kind of pure rouse
stupid boys I mean of all let me tell
you rapists don't kind of make a habit
of kind of loving a chat on Facebook
will go out and raping that's not the
kind of modus operandi right you know
well I'll just have a chat about it
before I do it and we do you know I mean
but this was kind of right so it has a
scaremongering impact on young women
demonizes all the male students that
were at universities and my original
point was there was something about that
chat and I've noticed it myself in terms
of things that happen on Twitter and
social media and young people I know who
personally as a way of kicking against
the you can't say that culture kind of
go into a kind of Milo Jana lopoliths
you know kind of feminism is cancer mode
almost out frustration yeah and I can
understand that psychologically because
you can't just be told you can never
speak about anything
you're not allowed it's one of the
reasons Jordan Peterson I think is so
popular as daddy he makes he makes all
these points and I could hear on way and
people go oh wait there is something
unexplained and here's someone who's
actually giving shape to some of the
things that I've been thinking about
there was a very interesting article in
The Times a couple of weeks back I don't
know if you saw it it's with Matthew
Parris when he wrote about the bad
behavior of the liberals in Ireland and
when it came to the abortion campaign
and he just said some of the way they
spoke to the Conservatives away they
demonize him the way they portrayed them
and he came out and said look the
classic thing I'm actually probable I
believe in women's rights were to have
an abortion
however I believe the behavior by the
campaign by some of the proponents of
the campaign was this
graceful and then you had people on
Twitter and whatever rails saying you
know he's disgusting what he's saying
and it was just I know but when did it
become reasonable just to be
unreasonable I know when did when - when
did we when did it become acceptable to
stop attacking other people and to be
vile just because they disagreed but
there's an a liberal liberalism isn't
that which is very dangerous
for those of us who have some
aspirations have fit under the liberal
heading liberal in the sense of being
and the liberal tradition is associated
with the Enlightenment of free thinkers
and that kind of it's the Liberals who
were leading the charge on this and I
and I felt equally squeamish about the
abortion debate by the way because I was
a reciting them from an Irish Catholic
background and I was very excited about
the island vote and about what happened
because you know it's a fantastic thing
and but and I never thought I'd say I
write but I hated some of those
campaigners because you know the thing
is also that you know people are allowed
in conscience to say that they think
that abortion is a sin is wrong is
morally wrong that is allowed right that
doesn't make the misogynist I think
they're wrong
I don't I don't agree with their
religious sensibility but you've got it
otherwise you basically abolish free
conscience and you basically say we
change the law you've got to go along
with it now well now you don't I mean if
the law is going to be the decider of
conscience
obviously that's authoritarian I mean
that's kind of fascist outlook that's
like a proper state controls your mind
stuff right and now I mean there's lots
of laws I disagree with I'm gonna say so
but in particularly in relation to
religious freedom it's hugely important
to defend religious freedom even if you
don't agree with it because that's the
basis on which you say we are a tolerant
society doesn't mean that I'm going to
it it doesn't mean that you shouldn't be
protected as in you know we can't say
that if you insult a religion that you
aren't going to be
for offensiveness but similarly you
gotta say that somebody has to follow
their conscience that's the basis on
which we are individual autonomous
citizens that's the only way it works
and again this is the infantilizing
process because if you've got only one
script to follow then actually you can
never grow up you don't need to hear the
other side of the argument do you
generally just have to learn the script
you learn the script anyone who doesn't
follow the script is a lunatic you were
correct yet you hateful should be banned
anyway because they're not following the
script and what well in terms of why
this does young people no favors is
because as soon as they encounter an
argument that is an argument because
they've they've actually not ever heard
an argument they can't maintain the
script because they're actually only
repeating something as it were by rote
they're not used to having to defend
that argument so I don't mean that they
should change their mind when they argue
with someone like me or anyone else but
but they they're so unused to the
argument that they actually collapse and
he's like God knew it so of course then
they associate and then they kind of
they definitely don't want those because
then because then it kind of might have
tamaki but you know that's what jazz
smell bringing explains that you don't
really understand that your arguments
right and unless it's kind of clashed
against unless you've heard the other
arguments that's he could not just say
my arguments right I know this cuz the
only argument I've heard it has to be
exposed to the light of the other
argument so you can work it out
and actually you might never change your
mind but you'll get better at arguing if
you expose yourself to other side
projects before you ask your next
question by the way the correct term is
pro-choice sir you said pro-abortion I
think it would have been a lot less
likely to get successful although in
fact for many years I think many of us
said that we were proud yeah
the reason why they kind of change it of
course was because I thought it might
put people off yes a marketing it's um
you made me forget my point the
constants in how day you know do you
think that this sort of polarization
we've got now I don't want to interact
with you because you're racist sexist
you're a snowflake blah blah blah do you
think it's giving rise to what we see
now in politics we have someone like
Trump on one hand Hillary on the other
that doesn't seem to be a middle ground
breaks it remain people screaming at
each other I think that the that they I
think that the echo chamber of fractal
the kind of the the sense of saying
following that script as I say it's
reflecting that I think it's all
slightly different I mean I I don't to
say yes but it's not quite right I mean
I think that and we know that chump one
of the reasons why Shankara elected was
because he he definitely appealed to
those people he felt that they were the
ones who weren't being listened to you
weren't following the script and really
you know part of the Left Behind
scenario it's not just an economic
left-wing and that's a misunderstanding
I think it was kind of aware of the fact
that there was this kind of whole
culture of brutal that probably the only
you that you had to support you know and
you know it was a toilets arguments on
transgender I can't really remember the
way but it's kind of like this sort of
you know if you don't agree with
transgender toilets then you're really
out you know demeaning people sort of
there was a big debate in America and
people just saw someone what what what
and so that I think that there was that
and then also identity politics informed
the people who invited for Hillary she
is she I'm sorry she ashamed that
identity would be one of the big things
so she didn't try and argue beyond that
and I think there's something of Trump's
appeal kind of said well there's one
identity gets ignored and that's the
white working-class and there was a kind
of element of that as well so I think
that there was only a reaction against
crudely put political correctness and
identity politics in Trump's vote but I
also think that Trump is kind of himself
a huge
a significant snowflake I mean he's like
for me the embodiment of snowflake we
you know surrounds himself by sick of
fantasy agree with him the whole time
and he's got a safe space and you know
lashes out any criticism and kind of
takes you know I tried to close it down
you know tried to ban anyone something
like the irony is is is that he himself
is kind of like a walking embodiment of
that kind of over spoiled and unable to
interact not prepared to debate type
person so I don't want to make any
virtues in relation to what I think is a
real problematic way that he's running
society the brexit but but on the other
hand I think that the way that the the
inability as explained by Mart Leela
brilliantly after after John got elected
he's a professor of humanities yelling
broke a fantastic article on identity
and in the New York Times innocent yeah
of course as a consequence gone on to be
now called an apologist for white
supremacism and but anyway easily yeah I
mean really serious and he's like a
serious humanities girl right and
professor but anyway he sort of said
that one of the problems was the the
inability of the kind of liberal your
young liberals to go beyond a kind of
narcissistic obsession with their own
identities that meant that they were
unable to reach out beyond them to gain
the votes of people not like themselves
and I think that that was quite an
astute he explained it but a better
quote that I just given but more or less
that and that really struck home right
home for me I think that in the build-up
to the brexit referendum into the
referendum I constantly was meeting
people in the circuits that I am
traveling who would say I mean has
anyone ever met a brexit supporter you
say yes well first of all I'm one and
they'd laugh because they're always
joking
yeah I was mostly like oh haha I said no
I'm gonna bet Brett's it cool but when
they'd say you know is anyone ever meta
brezin he's not so like get out more you
know I mean I mean you know
and subsequent at the bank people still
make these kind of comments when who's
met these boots like what you mean
there's an awful lot of them you should
know you don't know them right yeah
exactly
and in the builds of the referendum they
might at that point we might not have
known there was going to be a majority
but we didn't know there was a lot of
them right but in there was no
imagination so I think one of the
consequences of kind of identity
politics and the broader sense of sort
of saying our kind of people means that
there's this inability to understand the
world beyond people who follow the
script and ante assumed which is the
other thing because this is not just
equal side it is it I mean you know it's
not just that I mean it is to write off
choose ways of people as deplorable and
low information that is most distasteful
for me and so it's not a kind of equal
thing I mean you could say well of
course if you're living in you know part
you know if you're living in Sunderland
you also could don't understand the
worlds of being part of the Metropolitan
elite you know we've all got separate
lives right but it but but what I think
is most horrible is is that you know
people in the metropolitan elite if you
were often very influential and write
off people in parts of the country
because I haven't got qualifications is
being stupid and they'll informed rather
than just living a different life and
those kind of attitudes that emerged
have really grated and so that's made it
worse you know I mean I mean if you're
called a racist ignorant stupid person
because you voted brassy it's really
hard to not get wound up oh absolutely
and I find it very frustrating I mean
like Francis with mothers from Venezuela
I'm from Russia I came to this country
when I was 11 I we both would remain
right yeah we both might remain but what
I found incredible and very upsetting
actually is in the brexit campaign and
after the brexit campaign this idea that
British people are these races
xenophobes
is completely counter to every
experience I've had in this country I
mean this is one of the most tolerant
countries in the history of the world
but it's also the case that most people
who voted remain have accepted the
referendum was the
and I'm done so you know loads of my
friends won't remain loads of my friends
rated brexit
it was as you know it with lots of
people arguments before and afterwards
and you know my family was split but but
actually not in that way that everyone
is very acrimonious but I happy but I
have been really shocked by how a
substantial hardcore have kind of framed
the debate subsequent well in the
build-up to and subsequent of writing
off brexit voters but I've been
encouraged by how many of my remain
friends are also shocked as in the way
that you've said I mean it's given us an
insight into way things work in a way
that is like it's fine think rationally
but it's definitely kind of like a kind
of top you know it was kind of like it's
like one of these did you think oh my
god you know the establishment don't
like it when they lose you know like
that like these people don't like it
like that
there's Hulse ways of very influential
people
you are just furious and furious I will
never forgive and I'll not get
everything right and and whereas most
ordinary remember is the likes of Vogue
well that's a shame but now get we gotta
leave the game you have way and then
it's something you will end up in a
civil war and the the problem is is that
then the people who were kind of leading
the remain weren't giving they're not
letting this happen easily you've kind
of whipped up what then becomes a sort
of new form of identity politics whether
you're remain Oh or leave and I keep
trying to say and by the way we're not
the Institute of ideas anymore I should
just add that we've changed our name to
the Academy abiding caucus and the
Institute of ideas partly is word you
can't use the word Institute and so
after eighteen years we have to change
it because somebody complained so for a
time yes it was perfectly fine then and
now I suppose has got anything to do
with the post brexit you know make
people think what it could be but anyway
and but but I I think that it I've tried
to the academy of ideas work as a battle
of ideas festival that we organize I've
tried to say can we just go beyond these
labels can we just go and
say it doesn't matter but what's your
attitude now yeah I mean the one thing
that I find frustrating have a lot of
remain voters is this is that they vote
to remain and therefore that means
they're a good person
and I find it baffling especially when
they go oh I'm a Corbin Easter remainer
and I'm like well Corbin isn't probably
remain he's Corbin's a brexit ear if you
are hard left a lot of a lot you would
argue that's incompatible for voting for
the year exactly I mean I've I don't
know Jeremy Corbyn very well but let me
tell you the main ways that I've known
Jeremy Corbyn over the many years that
he's been involved in politics and I'm
kind of known him as somebody is because
of his attitudes to the EU he made a bad
night and anti-eu person all all my
political life that I've known and
you're right I mean so people don't
understand that bit but now it's you
know we haven't discussed virtue
signaling and I know you've got a stop
discussing everything but there is this
kind of I find it very galling that
people would say you know all these
ignorant brexit voters don't know
anything about the EU and I'd ask people
well let's talk about the EU then and
then you nothing about the you know what
they what they were saying was
particularly young people actually and
of course it was this kind of like as
your people were being betrayed you know
and then you use everything and you know
people say you know you how we gonna
travel yeah what are you talking about
you know sort of like well I mean II EU
and you know people would say things
like I kind of made this point you know
somebody said to me yeah but you and you
like Beethoven I mean what's wrong with
you I said well by the EU didn't create
Beethoven right you know I mean it's
like this sort of like everything but
you like European culture glad when
you'd be so answer you're in I'm not
into European about the EU particular
institution I think we should get out I
love Europe I consider myself to be
European you don't know what do you you
know but it became a I'm a good person
yeah and that became a closing down of
minds that the irony of saying that
people were ignorant bigots who were
voting Brett's it was that far too many
people before the vote assumed that you
would just vote remain if you were any
kind of a nice person who liked he was
international
we're looking that was it I might racist
and not racist no well I think that's
our time before we finish we always like
to ask one final question which is what
is the one issue that no one is talking
about that we should be talking about um
this is a slightly peculiar one but I I
think there's a real problem with
allowing the police to close down rap
videos on YouTube I think that the
issues of youth violence and crime in
society are underestimated and sorry the
the way that that issue has been used to
assault free speech and is is something
that we should look out for so there's a
consistent attempt by the police to
target certain types of music videos and
remove them from the web so that might
sound like white where she told me I did
not expect you to bring my music up I'm
at yeah no but I the reason why it's
important is because I mean it's
particularly drill music but I think
that the reason why it's important is
because these small little aspects of
the culture was kind of go on and
suddenly you get the headlights and
police saying that it's very important
to check whether the lyrics of songs and
incite violence you think what the head
of the Met and then in telling YouTube
to remove videos of types of music now
this seems like such a small thing that
you could just let it go
this is what's that got to do with
anything and you know Jim is hardly me
Jeremy I'm not a fan secondly all the
drill musicians here watching our thing
is thank God for that our credibility
because on the inland and she let this
state or indeed the the the big
corporates who run the social media
platforms remove types of music because
the lyrics don't pass the purity test is
one of those kind of free speech issues
that we should all make much more of a
fuss about
and so I suppose for me sometimes you
have to find these small issues and also
on the rap
Music Issue a nineteen-year-old
Liverpudlian girl was recently found
guilty because she posted a rap song on
her Instagram page after a 13 year old
was killed in a car accident and he
liked that rap singer she posted the
lyrics and over 1 rap song that
contained the n-word and as a
consequence she was found guilty of
section one two three I think it is a
communications act
she's on it she's found guilty she had
no criminal record for that and she she
was found guilty of race you know of
hate crime and she got a fine but she's
got a tag and she's got an 8 to 8 curfew
and a crew at 8 and night till 8:00 in
the morning curfew she's 19 and a
criminal record for hate crime which you
know racism right yeah because she likes
rap so these like little things right
and they chip way behind the scenes a
bit unfashionable and I don't you know
and a lot of the people who create drill
music are gang members and undoubtedly
some of them are savory and I might feel
a bit weird to say that somebody like me
should defend them but they're the hard
cases on free speech that we need to
defend so when we organize a big
festival about my dears festival which I
eat she'll come to you and also like
we've got loads of speakers you'll be
able to get let's talk about anyway
we're gonna have one of the big debates
gonna be on rap so all sorts of things
um yes that's one of my that's one of my
I want to talk about that a lot more it
seems you're the second person we've
spoken to today who's brought up the
issue of drill music yeah really yeah
yeah we'll talk about that after anyway
you're on Twitter and I'm on Twitter at
at Fox underscore Claire had Fox Fox
underscore Claire and if you follow
Claire also by her book I find that
offensive I'm not failing human I am at
Constance in kitchen and you want to do
the honors yes if you've enjoyed the
show which I hope you have done please
give us a rating on iTunes five stars
please leave a nice comment also as well
tell a friend share it um and yes that
glad to tell you to chat that's the one
that's a nice one subscriber you too
channel and thanks a lot for watching
see you next week